[Musique]
vous avez écrit georges perec dans w mon
projet d'écrire mon histoire ses formes
est presqu'en même temps que mon projet
d'écrire et cette histoire
elle commence je crois à belleville dans
cette rue vilain que vous avez décrit en
fait la rue maintenant n'est plus qu'un
vague souvenir de rue c'est une rue qui
est en train de mourir depuis des années
c'était une vague et
la maison ma mère avait sans son petit
magasin de la fumée est resté est encore
resté tout contenu de cette vision là
très bon mais buzzer fait la couverture
de ces l'axé la moto2 choisi ça va être
bizarre nouvelle donne je vais dans dans
cette rue pour essayer de la décrire de
seuil et de retrouver les unissent qui
me rattache et j'ai vécu avant la guerre
jusqu'à 42 et que je n'avais pas revus
ensuite pendant des années et des années
a généré découverte ensuite ans je crois
vers une chose seulement et j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps mais avant de
retrouver de me rendre compte que
c'était précisément ce que cette maison
et c'est cette part est pour moi c'est
le dire était le point de départ de
toute fin de match native
autobiographique qui était qui était
informe début je veux dire quand je dis
comment mon projet d'écrire
c'était d'abord le projet d'écrire mon
histoire mais j'ai mis très longtemps
avant de demander à percevoir du gratte
ciel mais votre future élite et à ses
sauces de votre vie des sources un peu
oublié parce que la guerre ça a été une
série sans continuité
je ne sais très liés ça aussi je
m'entends je veux dire avant de me de
l'assumer
avant d'assumer mon histoire comme tel
pouvant qu'ils ont la possibilité de
gears jeunes et
que dire de considérer comme d'arriver à
cerner quelque chose qui soit ma propre
histoire
mon propre espace mon propre lieu
précisément parce que les ces lieux ne
me semblait qu'il n'existe pas j'aime
beaucoup de temps disons à incorporer à
me sentir de niveau appartenant à sept
tours à cette nuit à ce quartier est à
cette époque qu est-ce que ce cynisme
éhonté travers l'état turc que vous êtes
réinsérer et est ce que voulait dire
l'écriture elle quelque chose qui a
traversé ce cet espace qui qui
maintenant est en tout cas habiter dans
mon souffle
[Musique]